there's no [__] women on the front
line in Ukraine that is silent [__]
they put some chick there dancing around
doing Pokemon dancers to try and
convince men to be a [__] die in a
ditch it's garbage if you go to the
front line of Ukraine right now you do
not see women in their makeup and their
manicures you see [__] men in the
freezing cold dying you know where the
women are Dubai chilling that's where
the women are so to sit and pretend that
women are just as capable physically as
men as a [__] lies delusion to send
the Earth's strongest man is delusion
you are good at other things you're
better than men at a lot of things but
it's not the physical world